[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire welcome and great to see
both of you lots to talk about obviously
so let's take a look then at the front
pages starting with the metro the metro
looks at what appears to be growing
momentum for penny morden's campaign
although she came second in the first
ballot she's consistently leading polls
of party members who will take part in
the final vote same angle for the
telegraph which pictures the former
defense secretary giving the thumbs up
the eye describes her performance as a
surge which will rattle her rivals
the daily mail leads with the message
from liz trust to the party right that
unless they unite now they will lose the
leadership the sun says the remaining
candidates have the sex factor
but the mirror attacks the candidates
for focusing on tax cuts for the rich
rather than helping people with the cost
of living crisis
the financial times reports that growing
inflation in the us is prompting calls
for its central bank the federal reserve
to raise interest rates
and on a lighter note the star carries
findings about how many people take
their dog to the pub
well a quick reminder by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us not sure why we need to know
how many people take their talk to the
pub but anyway andrew pierce and kevin
mcguhan are here um well one woman's
face andrew uh is on many a front page
what's going on
well she's you can never predict or a
leadership contest anna they are
unpredictable by their very nature not
least because the electorate involved
tory mps don't always tell it as it is
some might say they're duplicitous but
there's no doubt the momentum now in
this campaign is with penny morden she's
the international business minister
she's been defense secretary albeit not
very long uh she was an inter
international development sector so
she's had a raft of
senior ministerial jobs and what's
really intriguing not only is she in
second place ahead of liz trust the
foreign secretary you might have thought
would be
further
further would have got more mps but a
staggering poll frankly by yougov today
of conservative party members shows that
penny morton is way ahead but when you
put her head to head against the other
candidates by a country mile and here's
the thing rishi sunak the darling of the
uh uh who's had such a slick
well-organized uh campaign the darling
of some uh of the party he is on 27 to
her 67 percent she would knock him for
six now that will really focus tory mp's
minds as they vote tomorrow and then
again next week because they'll want to
perhaps
associate with the winner not least
because that way they get profit they
get ministerial jobs and if they think
the momentum is going penny morton's way
do they deserve sunak do they deserve
the foreign secretary who knows but i
think she's looking very very well
placed to be in the last two yeah i mean
it's early days obviously about who
might actually win that poll we've got
till september for all of this to to
wash through but uh we saw the daily
telegraph there more than seizes the
momentum the metro as well pm for pm i
mean that's manner for heaven and a
campaign slogan isn't it it's quite
memorable um and uh the eye as well
mordant surge rattles rivals in the race
for number ten who will be most
panicking is it liz trust kevin
i think so
rishi sunak will be worried too but as
you as you said anna that she's
dominating all the headlines she's her
picture is on most of the front pages
she is the one with momentum and
momentum in politics is all important
that's slogan pm for pm it's the only
slogan i can remember from any of the
candidates it's just a fortunate for her
her initials
work for it but liz truss is
underperformed and you look at that uh
showing that 50 she got uh mp's back and
ends against 67 against uh morden and of
course the male from paige is saying
look trust is saying that the right has
to unite or it'll lose she means unite
around herself which will mean uh suella
bravaman and kemi badanok pulling out
you know bravo man might pull out before
the ballot i could possibly see that i
can't really see kemi badanok pulling
out because she's doing quite well
herself and
it's an extraordinary position and a bit
of a
turn up for the books given that
sunak and trust have been campaigning
for uh months if not years although
speaking to a labor show a cabinet
member tonight who said whenever
she went along to events and penny
mordant was there everybody at the event
labour mps as well as tory mps would get
a little note from her afterwards you're
very polite all that pays off because
she's a fresh face but she'll come under
scrutiny now morden you can't say she's
a big break when as andrew said she's
been uh the international development
secretary she's been the defense
secretary as he said not not for very
long and she
remains the trade
minister in johnson's regime and didn't
resign to try and force him out so she
can't just say she's fresh but people
know very little
about us so the conservatives can sell
something they want but she will come
under scrutiny now people begin to dig
it into what she said what she would do
in a way she's had an easy ride so far
kevin let's see andrew wants to come in
sorry yeah yeah but what i would say
though is what what kevin's right to
point out she's been a minister for a
long time but she's not been in the
cabinet rishi sooner is the or rishi
soon that's trying to blame boris
johnson for the huge tax rises sorry
he's the child he was a chance of the
it's checker has taken our tax burden to
its highest level for 70 odd years and
liz class as foreign secretary we know
she opposed that in cabaret and she did
she spoke out very loudly in cabinet
against it but she has been part of the
boris johnson cabinet right from the
very beginning so she's very associated
too so people mps and story party faith
who are looking for a break and a
cleaner break would certainly be looking
at penny morton yeah but five five of
the six left uh left in tom tugan that's
the exception that they're ministers in
the johnson regime and yet they're now
running against their own government
they stood on a 2019 manifesto most of
them voted to break the promises in it
blaming covert
so you cannot just pretend it the past
has nothing to do with them they've got
to own their voting records and what
they've done in it if it was to cling on
a red boxes keep a chauffeur driven car
and have an office well you've got to be
held accountable for that but there's no
doubt that uh hms penny and she's said
to be named after hms uh penelope uh
which is a warship i hope she uh or
she'll hope to do better than that
because it's sung with a huge loss of
life in the second world war uh but she
she is plowing ahead and she could she
could win it and the telegraph point out
that in 1997 2001 2005 in those tory
leadership contests the winner was who
came second in the first round so it was
william william uh william hague ian
duncan smith david cameron of course
2019
boris johnson uh boris johnson won the
that rule wasn't followed but she she
could come from that second position she
gets in that she gets on the final two
then it looks like she will win it now
and beat sunak his place is awesome
and so the question is i suppose is
there any panic in the um you know
conservative ranks or in the
parliamentary party at least that
actually somebody's winning it who's not
very well known we're talking about a
general election and only a couple of
years andrew this is i mean this is that
you've got to get up to speed really
quickly haven't you
yeah but i said i know i don't think
they are panicking at all i think
they're looking at her in the same way
they looked at david cameron a long time
ago who knew to who david cameron was
now they were in opposition then of
course but young uh are they telegenic
they thought oh god he could win they
look at penny morton and she's telegenic
she looks good she speaks well it was a
very good launch today she made some
quite good jokes about the the trans row
that she's been people have tried to get
her involved in uh and uh and they think
uh actually she's got plenty of time to
convince the public uh and it's always
different it'll be difficult for
kierstarma i don't think keir stammer
would particularly want to be up against
uh penny morgan at the dispatch box i
don't think he'd mind
um liz trust so much and he certainly
wouldn't mind taking on rishi soon at
because he is an unknown quantity and
actually at the dispatch box he's very
good he's got a quick good turn of
phrase and he's very funny yes kirsten
certainly isn't yes and the daily mirror
your paper then kevin uh cost of living
crisis what cost of living crisis as
it's revealed struggling brits use
washing up liquid to clean their hair
what do tory candidates suggest cut tax
for the the rich and slash the state you
know what does she stand for we might as
well use this opportunity to to get to
know her
no no absolutely and she will uh as a
hustling star including on sky
uh we will we will then begin to to see
people may not like her as much as they
do when they don't like her there's no
there's no guarantee people will
actually warm to to her but certainly in
the cost of living there's been so much
focus on cutting uh the corporation tax
rise well that's 17 billion quid that
will go to mainly big big companies so
that you could need a focus on what
people want not uh not what conservative
uh candidates to be prime minister want
because they're going for an electorate
that doesn't
the party members that does not reflect
the country as a whole
andrew did you want to come in
i just want to say one thing what's
really interesting as well we've been
talking about how we know that rishi
tsunak and pen and liz trust have been
campaigning for the leadership but
jeremy corb jeremy um hunt who lost to
boris johnson in 2019 has been virtually
campaigning every day since the best
part of three years and it all ended
today with 18 votes out of 358 a really
brutal humiliation for jeremy hunt who's
a nice bloke but really was never going
to get the job and i just don't know why
i put his head above the parapet yet
again why don't they know when it's over
it's over yeah and suggesting today you
only get one shot at this and uh he had
his but he had his back then he of
course tonight has come out in support
of rishi sunak it'd be interesting to
see that won't help much you know it'll
be how
see where the votes of uh uh nadim
zahawi and um jerry hunt go and uh you
know tomorrow we roll onto more hustings
and another and another vote uh kevin
how do you think this one will shake
down
yeah now that's right they're going to
start falling out um
you know what we're now we're now down
to that that's six
bravo men will be out i would have
thought next some way and then what
happens to two gundat and khan
kemi bada not overtake liz tross because
sunak and morden are pulling ahead
otherwise truss is going to be
another big victory she's just not done
as well as she expected
word in westminster she's going to make
a big speech tomorrow well she's a very
poor public speaker liz trust unless
she's going on about she's and losing
everybody
so i i think her campaign is in in quite
serious serious trouble you can now see
the final two sunak and morton and
unless something come along there's an
event
it changes the minds of those tory
voters those tory party members which
make up a tiny tiny proportion of the
country it doesn't it does look like it
will be pm for pm and very quickly
andrew um will the papers come out for a
candidate is the daily mail got a chosen
candidate
um we we're not we haven't said yet no
um we would want the candidate to be as
a brexiteer because we want to make sure
brexit we really do start to get the
benefits um i don't think i think it's
fair to say we won't be supporting uh
rishi sunat because um he's lumbered us
with this huge tax burden and we
campaigned long and hard against those
tax risers but we've got them and no
other country in europe are busy putting
taxes up as we teeter potentially on the
edge of recession so it won't be him
that's for sure and we're very
we're like jeremy hunt very much we're
very glad he's out as well okay
no good that could be the whole program
couldn't it what the daimyo thinks about
them anyway lots more still to come
including worries over water shortages
as the heatwave continues we'll talk
about that next
[Music]
watching the press preview with me once
again andrew pearce and kevin mcguire
welcome back to both of you um kevin
let's go to sri lanka shall we you know
first the president now the prime
minister's offices some extraordinary
scenes there as they battle effectively
government poverty energy prices lack of
fertilizer you name it i know it is a
real economic crisis for ordinary
surroundings who are struggling to
survive and it's it's a revolution
there's the president he uh was it gotta
buy uh
raja rajapaskar i think it is as
uh fled he's gone off to the maldives
the prime minister's stepping down you
know the the brothers who were in
command and treating the the countries
if it was a a family business well
they're paying a high price for it
because uh ordinary sir lankans have
paid a high price but it's you you just
hope it's going to remain relatively
peaceful uh the police and be told by
the prime minister to do whatever is uh
required during uh the state of
emergency but you hope the police will
and the army will just be sensible
understand people have genuine
grievances and with the president gone
the pm going why defend them defend the
people not the politicians who plunged
srilanka into such a crisis
um andrew i was going to move on but i
think you want to say something about
this as well i just want to say
the odd thing is it's a sort of almost
preserved thing which caused this it was
the banning of um fertilizers fertilizer
imports because they wanted to make the
country more organic completely
destroyed the rice crop which then
caused all sorts of problems for the
economy price rises and uh and of course
also the present and his brother are
rotten and corrupt
and tourists have stopped going to sri
lanka too because of the pandemic and
because of the terror attacks
and it's so sad because it's such a
beautiful wonderful country
um let's go to the heatwave shall we and
the telegraph and a number of the
newspapers actually going on water
shortages now would a company suggesting
they're struggling to process and pump
out water quickly enough uh we certainly
know had no water at home yesterday and
at a point today as well
so i know what they mean but i mean
there's been no rain in parts of
southern britain for a very long time
properly now andrew
i know i get that but you know it's
always it's always our fault isn't it
with these water companies do you know
how many gallons of water get wasted
every year through leaks i really mean
it it's it's equivalent of something
like 1200 olympic-sized swimming pools
every day in england and wales disappear
down the drain because these wretched
water companies don't do their proper
care and maintenance and sort the leaks
out it's a scandal really when you
consider also how much they charge us
for our water rates and how much the fat
cap directors of the water companies are
earning yeah but we've had both of those
arguments for decades perhaps now a
little bit like gas storage we need to
work out that actually we need to save
more of our winter rain you know as we
move forward i don't know what solutions
you can proffer kevin
yeah it's very good actually uh to hear
andrew speaking out against another
botched privatization uh waters
community owned in wales but in england
it's a terrible privatization just like
your rail terrible privatization come on
andrew let's just reverse them both take
a minute of public ownership run them as
public services
instead of sending dividends to
profit-hungry
speculators many of whom in the water
industry certainly at some extent in
rail don't believe it
it's it's an argument of the 1980s i
fear anyway yeah yeah also also anna
could we just point out his beloved
version of nationalization they've done
that in scotland it's called scot rail
and they've had a 30 cut in services so
nationalization kevin my dear is not the
answer we just need these companies to
run
my
my dear gentlemen we run out of time
oh dear
um andrew and kevin thank you both very
much indeed lovely to see you both thank
you